premièrement s'agissant des événements
du 1er mai je voulais vous demander à
quel moment précis vous en avez eu
connaissance
et deuxièmement comment s'explique
à votre avis le fait que ces événements
s'étant déroulés dans cette journée en
présence de fonctionnaires de police et
de crs il n'y ait eu aucun compte rendu
de fait ni au préfet de police ni au
ministre de l'intérieur qui nous ont dit
l'un et l'autre avoir été informée le
lendemain par l'intermédiaire de les
lycées mais c'est le co-rapporteur donc
nous ouvrons ici les questions sur le
premier mais ce que je vais faire j'en
suis désolé ça va être un petit peu long
mais je voulais vous retracer la
chronologie du 1er mai pour qu'on soit
bien d'accord puisque quand vous me pose
une question en me disant est ce que
l'événement du 1er mai a fait l'objet
d'un compte-rendu moi l'événement du 1er
mai je vais vous le dire très
directement le 1er mai au soir
l'événement du 1er mai pour moi c'est
pas monsieur benalla un très clairement
le 1er mai au soir pour moi l'événement
de la journée c'est que j'ai passé 10
heures à faire de l'ordre public sur le
terrain que j'ai réalisé avec deux
autres commissaires de police trois
compagnies républicaines de sécurité et
deux engins lanceur d'eau une poussée de
1200 black block individus cagoulés
gantés porteurs de cocktails molotov
j'ai récupéré 6 cocktails molotov que
j'ai pris en photo par ailleurs qui sont
parlées dans la presse et que pendant
deux heures sur le boulevard de
l'hôpital de 15 heures à 17 heures on a
manoeuvré en faisant usage de gaz
lacrymogènes et de grenades de
désencerclement et d'engins lanceur
d'eau dans une atmosphère qui était
extrêmement dégradée et la question pour
moi n'était pas de savoir où était
monsieur benalla la question pour moi
était de savoir comment manoeuvre
comment on commet comme on essaye de ne
pas trop blé avoir de blessés dans les
rangs des forces de l'ordre et dans les
rangs de la crs qui est à mes côtés
l'acr 10 15 de béthune qui est une
excellente crs
et commencer pour intervenir le plus
rapidement sur le mcdonald's qui était
gravement empiré à partie ça c'est mon
business du 1er mai c'est ça pour moi
l'événement important du 1er mai le
deuxième événement important du premier
mais vous savez ce que c'est mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est la place
de la contrescarpe mais ce n'est pas
l'interpellation des deux personnes qui
venaient manger des crêpes nous dit-on
place de la contrescarpe pour moi
c'était un rassemblement de 80 à 100
personnes dont les services de
renseignement nous avaient dit qu'ils
étaient il avait participé de manière
très direct et très volontaire aux
dégradations importantes et aux
déprédations sur le boulevard de
l'hôpital et services de renseignement
et c'est assez rare pour le souligner
c'est passer sur les ondes de la dopc
saison deux là sont enregistrés dont
vous pourrez retrouver cette information
là on nous a dit texto les services de
renseignement nous font savoir que le
bon public le bon public en jargon
police ça veut dire les individus
autonomes de la mouvance contestataire
radicales sont présents sur la place de
la contrescarpe est très clairement il
n'était pas là pour faire un pique nique
donc moi ma deuxième priorité de la
journée du 1er mai c'était d'éviter
qu'ils un cortège sauvage à travers le
quartier latin
si 80 ou 100 individus étaient partis de
la place de la contrescarpe en cortège
sauvage je vous assure qu'il aurait
ravagé le quartier latin comme ils le
font habituellement dans d'autres
quartiers quand il parle de ménilmontant
quand il parle de ses secteurs de
l'agglomération parisienne
il nous aurait commis de très nombreuses
dégradations mois les instructions qui
étaient les miennes je ne prends pas je
prends des instructions très précises de
la salle d'information et de
commandement
c'était 2-1 protéger le quartier latin
de éviter un départ en cortège sauvage
de ces individus-là et 3 intervenir
très rapidement sur les barricades qui
pouvait être monté ce que j'ai fait
puisque sur la journée du 1er mai j'ai
été libéré à 23h du quartier latin et de
20 heures à 23 heures je suis intervenu
il ya beaucoup de vidéos qui témoignent
de sa avec la crs 15 sur un certain
nombre de barricades dans les rues pot
de fer l'oman clotilde ou tourne fort
voilà pour moi les deux événements
importants
le 1er mai à la fin de la journée bien
évidemment le 2 mai le 2 mai il ya un
second tour un autre événement qui
devient également important qui est la
fameuse vidéo